Bud Light has officially been overtaken
as the number one beer in America
by Modelo Modelo which Modelo is owned
by transheiser Bush outside of North
America so it's the same company but in
North America it's not it's owned by
constellation Brands what was an
American brand Budweiser then sells out
to the belgians the unsuper lib and now
the number one beer in America is a
Mexican brand
and now they're the number one beer in
America love it Modelo Especial made up
8.4 percent of retail beer sales while
Bud Light made up just 7.3 percent of
retail beer sales for the week ending
June 3rd get me a sombrero get me a big
silly mustache
yo soy Mexicano today porque
no no me gusta El Prado no me gusta El
rainbow flago so someone please I know
it's only eight o'clock here but I would
love to sip on a delicious Modelo and we
should keep it up